Meet Carl.
Carl just purchased a Toshiba Satellite S Series laptop.
He was initially attracted to the premium brushed aluminum ice blue finish,...
...which to Carl is a symbol of power and domination.
From empowering employees...
Sure thing, boss.
...to power trips and power lunches.
Carl demands power and performance in everything he does.
Which is why he elected for the Satellite S Series with an Intel i7 quad-core processor.
Its power and performance perfected.
And when Carl puts in a late night,...
...the full-size raised tile backlit keyboard will illuminate that ten key like a beacon in the night.
Calculate those calculations, Carl.
Nothing can stop you now.
He's closing deals at all hours without ever leaving his desk...
...with his high-def webcam and chambered Harman/Kardon speakers.
This kind of firepower is like Carl can be anywhere, almost real life.
It looks like that meeting paid off, Carl.
Time to grab that HD display with LED backlighting and meet the boys for Happy Hour.
For Carl, it's always Happy Hour with his Toshiba Satellite S Series.
Well played sir, well played.